à vos des marques prêt soldé dans cette
boutique vendeuse et clientes sont dans
les starting-blocks des promotions à
-20% sont déjà affichées alors autant
passer directement à la vitesse
supérieure va pas bien travailler à
cause de tous les manifestations tous
les samedis mais presque personne comme
on l'a plus de personnes un peu plus
âgées ils vont plus grand v là tous les
samedis et donc cela il m'a vraiment plu
comme c'est assez calme on préfère quand
même moi je préfère que les choses
avancent
si c'est possible j'ai fait attention
aux sites à programmer mais les achats
ont pensé que peut-être pendant les
soldes plus tôt l' enthousiasme n'est
pas partagé de l'autre côté de la rue
vendre à prix sacrifié ce qui n'est pas
parti en décembre ne rattrapera pas le
chiffre d'affaires envolée la réserve
est plein de marchandises anticipé le
solde au lendemain des fêtes serait un
travail de dingue pour les préparer les
salles de monsieur donc on n'a pas
d'étiquette seule fois les hacher les
étiquettes et tout c'est férié
on va tomber dans le jour de l'an c'est
férié donc je pense pas qu'on va venir
travailler jour de l'an pour étiqueter
c'est ça le souci c'est que il y aurait
fallu prévoir un petit peu avant parce
que là ça fait juste sa matrice elle est
toujours favorable à hama des articles
soldés plutôt un c'est sûr mais j'ai
entendu ce que vous a répondu la dame
cédric pourrait apparemment ça pose un
problème
il y aussi une certaine hypocrisie
ressenti à maintenir des dates
obligatoire alors que les ventes soient
disant privés ont déjà commencé partout
dès le lendemain de noël
toute l'année on fait des promos ont
fait des alors maintenant elle est seule
c'est fini six semaines c'est long et ça
a plus de valeur sa plus de valeur comme
comme il ya 15 20 ans quoi se
terminèrent pour les commerçants
l'inconnu n'est finalement pas le début
officiel des soldes mais plutôt ce qu'il
restera dans le porte-monnaie des
clients